versailles versailles qui resplendit ça
y est après huit ans de travaux les
appartements sont enfin restauré
inauguré ce soir par françois léotard le
ministre de la culture
les travaux commencés en soixante dix
huit dont on compte ainsi restaurer tout
le rez-de-chaussée les appartements mais
aussi le musée de l'histoire de france
un événement considérable pour tous les
visiteurs du château ils sont nombreux
bien sûr nous en parlerons avec pierre
lemoine conservateur en chef de
versailles
pierre champetier tout de suite nous
fait visiter les nouveaux appartements
il y avait les matériaux des boiseries
splendide authentique qui dormaient dans
les réserves depuis le xviiie siècle
comme on voit il en reste encore
il y avait les plans avant de casser les
murs pour son musée d'histoire
l'architecte frédéric neveu avaient été
relevées jusque dans les moindres
détails les appartements qu'on donne à
souvenirs pour le wifi sans cet essaim
rien n'aurait été possible
il y avait aussi le savoir-faire d'une
poignée d'artisans successeur talentueux
de ceux qui ont construit et décorer le
château il y avait enfin quelques
meubles d'origine acheté par l'état ou
généreusement offerts par des
particuliers
barbara hutten la duchesse de windsor il
y avait donc tout ce qu'il fallait pour
faire renaître après sept ans de travaux
les fameux appartement du
rez-de-chaussée où vécut le dauphin l'as
deux fines et mesdames fille de oui car
avec ces précieux petits cabinets de
derrière qui servait de refuge à
l'intimité des princes
le résultat le voici
éblouissant à la place du musée triste
et poussiéreux de plain pied avec les
fleurs les jets d'eau fraîche lumineuse
souriante 38 salles reconstitué à
l'identique les boudoirs les
bibliothèques les petits salons les
cabinets travail où le dauphin
s'ennuyait avec la dauphine ou
mademoiselle victoire et mademoiselle
adélaïde se gaver de gâteaux et de
chocolat avant d'aller taper sur le
clavecin mieux que les appartements
d'apparat et les salons officiels
il évoque la maison royale
le versailles habité celui de la vie
quotidienne tout aussi luxueux que
l'autre mais avec en plus une petite
touche de confort bourgeois qui nous le
rend plus sensible entre les nouveaux
appartements sous la galerie des glaces
la galerie basse elle aussi resterait
débarrasser de ses cloisons louis
philippe
plus étonnant encore l'escalier de
gabriel l'architecte du rhône
jusqu'à aujourd'hui il n'existait que
sur le papier à l'état de plans marie
antoinette avait fait interrompre les
travaux pour dresser un théâtre dans la
cage la république terminant l'ouvragé
des rois jusqu'où peut mener le bout de
la restauration